100 years ago the Magnificent Potsdamer
train station stood on this port a
carriage with latina layin on board
stopped here in the spring of 1917 Lane
wanted to return to Russia he wanted
rather it was the Imperial authorities
who loudly in strands it through Germany
during World War one the original
documents that put this fateful alliance
of convenience in effect are on display
in Berlin's German Historical Museum a
German diplomat sent in telegram to
Berlin it read Lenin arrived safely in
Russia he's doing just what you want it
says here ten million German marks for
political propaganda in Russia and some
ones corrected it to say 15 million we
found a lot of documents there were huge
sums involved as many as 2 million
Russians fled their homeland after the
1917 revolution they escaped and fear of
civil war terror and starvation it was
mainly the intellectual elite who were
scorned by the Bolsheviks doctor's
enterpreneurs writers officers and
aristocrats their lives in exile were
shaped by fear of an unknown future
maria von Moltke was born to a russian
noble family her father mitra Etruscan
was a cadet in the Marine Academy of st.
Petersburg he fled Russia a few months
after the Revolution at the age of
sixteen if you ask me where my home is I
have no home I have no home because I
feel at home nearly everywhere I mean
I've been to many places and I can
adjust after many detours through Serbia
Slovenia and Germany for Martha's family
settled in the US as did many other
Russians who fled after the Revolution
you had the highest the aristocracy who
was working in factories and doing work
which brought in pay
the pay was you could live on something
is and it was very very difficult
for many excelled Russians Berlin was
the first stop here they could unwind
and recover from the chaos back home
getting visas to enter Germany was a
relatively simple process at the border
many Russian refugees were granted
political asylum Charlottenburg at a
district where most of the 300,000
Russian settled was nicknamed charlatan
brat Berlin was a magnet to the Russian
intelligentsia the reasons might sound
familiar Berlin was cheap tolerant and
in the best sense and different the port
Andrew Bailey praised Berlin's easygoing
atmosphere with passages such as night
cocaine vets Berlin it was here that
latina Nabokov wrote his most famous
novels in Russian and the celebrated
author Boris Pasternak lived in the same
area it was a city within a city
Nicola gives guided to us about the
Russian exiles in Berlin in the 20s I
had people who came here enjoyed a lot
of freedom there were 87 Russian
language publishing houses there were
plenty of Russian restaurants Russian
Orthodox churches and workers
associations so for the people who fled
hunger there was plenty to eat it wasn't
just about waiting to see what would
happen in Russia people had a good life
here but many Russian stayed only a
short time here before heading to Paris
or New York
most of the exiled Russians like Mary
fan Malika's father never saw the
homeland again he left his diary to her
and with it a love for his native
language and Russian culture